cuando las personas descubrieron que las
partículas de materia como el electrón
podrían tener longitudes de onda y
cuando d'hebron descubrió que la
longitud de onda es la constante de
planck entre el momento de la partícula
pero algunas personas dijeron haber un
momento este particular tiene una
longitud de onda y un comportamiento
parecido al de una onda pero que es
exactamente lo que está ondulando a que
se refiere esta onda conceptualmente es
un poco extraño es decir nosotros
sabemos perfectamente que es una onda en
el agua un montón de agua que oscila de
arriba a abajo una onda en una cuerda
sabemos que es cuando la misma cuerda se
mueve de arriba a abajo y se extiende a
través del espacio pero es difícil de
imaginar cómo es que este electrón tiene
una longitud de onda y cuál es la onda
en sí misma los físicos estaban lidiando
con este problema comprender
conceptualmente cómo describir la onda
de un electrón
ellos querían dos cosas una era la
descripción matemática de la forma de
esa onda a esto le llamamos la función
de la onda y la función de onda nos da
una descripción matemática de la forma
de la onda diferentes sistemas de
electrones tendrán diferentes funciones
de onda esta es la letra griega sí y es
el símbolo de las funciones de onda y es
una función de x por lo que en
diferentes puntos de x podríamos tener
un valor mayor o un valor más pequeño
por lo que esta función nos dará la
forma matemática de esta onda lo que es
una de las cosas que queremos determinar
pero la otra cosa es poder interpretarla
qué es lo que significa en sí misma esta
función de onda así que tenemos dos
problemas
queremos una descripción matemática de
la onda y queremos interpretar qué
significa esta onda la persona que nos
dio la descripción matemática de esta
función de onda fué erwin schrödinger
harding er es esta persona y él escribió
la ecuación de schrödinger y ahora su
nombre básicamente es sinónimo de la
mecánica cuántica ya que esta es una de
las ecuaciones más importantes de toda
la mecánica cuántica
aquí tenemos varias derivadas parciales
y constantes de planck pero lo
importante es que aquí está la función
de la onda si ustedes nunca han visto
las derivadas parciales o el cálculo no
se preocupen no tienen que saberlo al
menos para el propósito de este vídeo
solo deben saber que esta ecuación es
una forma de obtener matemáticamente
esta función de onda nos da la forma de
la onda como función de x y pueden
imaginar que la gráfica nos ya que
encontramos estas y como función de x
podemos graficar la quizá en este caso
luzca así pero la ecuación de
schrödinger es la forma en la que
podemos obtener esta ecuación de onda
así que schrödinger nos proporciona una
manera de obtener
esta función de onda pero que es lo que
significa el decir que esta función de
onda representa a la onda del electrón
es muy extraño rodinger trato de
interpretarla de esta manera él dijo
quizá este electrón está distribuido en
el espacio y su carga está distribuida
en diferentes lugares yo tenga quiso
interpretar esta función de la onda como
la densidad de la carga y quizás sea
algo razonable la forma en la que
tenemos una onda en el agua es teniendo
al agua distribuida en el espacio así
que la forma en que obtenemos una onda
de electrón quizá es teniendo la carga
del electrón distribuida en el espacio
pero esta descripción no funcionaba bien
lo que es extraño rodinger inventó esta
ecuación pero no era capaz de
interpretarla aunque si pudiera
describirla correctamente fue otra
persona llamada max born quien dio la
interpretación que ahora usamos para
esta función de onda más
bon dijo no interpreten esto como la
densidad de la carga deben interpretar
esta sim como una manera de obtener la
probabilidad de encontrar al electrón en
cierto punto en el espacio así que tomen
la ecuación de schrödinger para
encontrar la función de onda y una vez
que encuentren así lo que van a hacer es
elevar así al cuadrado tomamos el valor
absoluto y lo elevamos al cuadrado y
esto les dará la probabilidad de
encontrar al electrón en cierto punto
técnicamente es la densidad de
probabilidad pero para nuestros
propósitos pueden pensar en esto como la
probabilidad como la probabilidad de
encontrar al electrón en cierto punto si
esta es la función de nuestra onda max
born nos dice que si en estos puntos la
función vale cero tendremos un cero por
ciento de probabilidad de encontrar un
electrón ahí en los puntos donde hay un
valor grande de pepsi ya sea positivo o
negativo habrá una mayor probabilidad d
un electrón en este punto y podemos
decir que la probabilidad de encontrar
un electrón en cierto punto aquí será
mayor para el valor de x aquí ya que es
aquí en donde tenemos la mayor magnitud
de la onda pero no necesariamente vamos
a encontrar aquí al electrón si
repitiéramos el experimento una y otra y
otra vez podrían encontrar al electrón
aquí o aquí o acá hay que seguir tomando
medidas y si tomamos las suficientes nos
encontraremos que esta distribución en
donde nos encontramos al electrón muy
seguido por acá y bastante por aquí por
acá
y por allá siempre encontraremos más
seguido al electrón en donde tengamos
estos picos al menos comparado con la
frecuencia de que encontremos al
electrón en estos otros puntos de aquí
se tiene una distribución que está
representada por esta función la función
de onda no nos dice en donde se
encontrará el electrón sino la
probabilidad aunque técnicamente es el
cuadrado de eps y lo que nos da la
probabilidad de encontrar al electrón en
cierto punto aún en este punto en donde
nuestra si tiene un valor negativo es
decir no podemos tener probabilidades
negativas pero elevamos este valor al
cuadrado y nos da la probabilidad de
encontrar un electrón en esta región
en otras palabras vamos a quitar esto y
digamos que resolvimos una ecuación de
schrödinger y encontramos una función de
onda que luce así y nos pregunten en
donde será más probable que encontremos
un electrón bueno el valor más grande de
esta función está en este punto por lo
que es más probable encontrar un
electrón en estado
en cambio aquí no tenemos probabilidad
alguna de encontrar un electrón por acá
tenemos bastante probabilidad de
encontrar un electrón o por aquí pero la
mayor probabilidad está en esta región
por lo que tenemos que realizar varias
veces esta medición en la mecánica
cuántica una sola medición no nos
garantiza que tengamos la función de
onda correcta ya que si hago un
experimento y encuentro un electrón aquí
no me dirá nada tengo que repetir esto
muchas veces para asegurarme de que la
frecuencia relativa con la que encuentro
electrones coincide con la función que
estoy usando para modelar este sistema
de electrones esto es la función de onda
y esto es para lo que nos sirve pero si
yo fuera ustedes aún no estaría
satisfecha y diría
un momento esto está muy bien la función
de onda nos da la probabilidad o la
densidad de probabilidad para encontrar
un electrón en cierta región pero aún no
respondemos qué es lo que está ondulando
aquí y qué es exactamente esta función
de onda es un objeto físico como una
onda del agua o como una onda
electromagnética o es solo brujería
matemática que usamos y que no tiene una
interpretación física que no sea el
informarnos en donde puede estar el
electrón les tengo buenas noticias y
malas noticias la mala noticia es que
las personas aún no se ponen de acuerdo
sobre cómo interpretar esta función de
onda aunque saben que esta función nos
dice cuál es la probabilidad de
encontrar un electrón en una región
particular pero no se ponen de acuerdo
sobre cómo deben interpretar la función
más allá de esto por ejemplo esta
función de onda corresponde a un solo
elector o es la función de onda de un
sistema de electrones
los preparados de manera similar al
experimento que vamos a realizar en
otras palabras describe a un electrón
solamente oa un conjunto de electrones
no describe para nada al electrón y solo
describe nuestra medida del electrón y
qué le pasa a esta función cuando
medimos realmente este electrón cuando
medimos un electrón y lo encontramos en
cierto lugar significa que ya no tenemos
la probabilidad de encontrarlo en ningún
otro lugar así que el acto de medir al
electrón causa un colapso catastrófico
en esta ecuación que no se describe en
la ecuación de schrödinger estas y
muchas otras preguntas se están
debatiendo y no se comprenden por
completo estas son las malas noticias la
buena noticia es que no necesitamos
comprender todo esto para progresar
todos saben cómo usar la función de onda
para obtener la probabilidad de las
mediciones ustedes pueden tener su
interpretación favorita pero
afortunadamente sin importar cómo
interpretamos esta función siempre y
cuando obtengamos
rectamente las probabilidades de las
mediciones podremos seguir progresando y
probando mediciones y probando nuevos
modelos y ccoo relacionando información
de las mediciones que las personas
obtienen en sus laboratorios y no digo
que las interpretaciones de esto no sean
importantes las personas han tratado de
resolver esto durante los últimos 100
años y aún no han podido quizá eso sea
una pérdida de tiempo o quizás sea aún
tremendamente difícil interpretar y la
persona que lo logre pasar a la historia
como uno de los más grandes físicos de
todos los tiempos aún no tenemos la
respuesta pero lo que ha quedado claro
en estos cien años es que podemos hacer
progresos en mecánica cuántica aún
cuando no estemos de acuerdo en cómo
interpretar lo que representa esta
función de onda en resumen la función de
onda nos da la probabilidad de encontrar
un electrón en cierta región
particularmente el cuadrado de la
función de onda particularmente el
cuadrado de la función de onda nos da la
densidad de la probabilidad
de encontrar una partícula en este punto
en el espacio casi todos están de
acuerdo en esto pero las implicaciones
más profundas además de esto aún no
están definidas pero eso no nos impide
aplicar correctamente la mecánica
cuántica en diversos escenarios